Mr. Ide, the suit is kind of lagging.
Lagging?
The suit is operating normally.
I think the time is about right, Ide.
All right.
-Shinjiro.
-Mr. Ide?
I'm going to disengage the limiter
on the suit now.
Limiter?
Think of it as a way to bring out
your ultimate abilities.
All right.
However, when the limiter is disengaged,
you and the suit can only last
three minutes.
So, the next time he comes at you
will be your last chance.
Disengage the limiter!
You sure are tenacious.
Wow! Isn't that
the danger signal that goes off
just before you fall apart?
No.
This isn't any danger signal.
This is the signal for me
to use all my power...
to kick your ass.
My left arm!
I won't stand for this.